bonjour et bienvenue à tous sur lcp
public sénat c'est l'heure de parents de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour refaire
l'aktu politique et parlementaire avec
michaël szames s bonjour à tous les
sénateurs examinaient cette semaine le
projet de loi travail près de mille
amendements ont été déposés beaucoup sur
l'article de voter cette semaine qui
donne la primauté aux accords
d'entreprise objet principal de la
discorde la droite sénatoriale a
entièrement réécrit le texte en prenant
notamment la fin des 35 heures la france
sous tension et sous les menaces frappés
par le terrorisme islamiste à magna
ville où des policiers ont été
assassinés des violences aussi en marche
de l'euro de foot des manifs ou les
casseurs haute à filtrer les cortèges
prenant notamment à par l'hôpital necker
à paris
et puis la loi sapin de adopté en
première lecture à l'assemblée une loi
large périmètre puisqu'elle s'attaque à
la fois la lutte contre la corruption au
pouvoir des lobbys à l'encadrement des
salaires des grands patrons le texte
prévoit aussi de mieux protéger les
lanceurs d'alerté
l'autre invité cette semaine pour
détailler toute cette semaine très
politique dit guillaume bonjour bonjour
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
au moment où on parle ni guillaume est
un hommage national aux deux policiers
assassinés cette semaine peut-être votre
témoignage sur cet hommage national oui
je moi je voudrais avoir une pensée pour
jean baptiste salins jessica schneider
et leurs enfants et leurs familles vous
savez ce matin moi ça faisait longtemps
que ça ne m'était pas arrivé mais j'ai
eu les larmes aux yeux
faux pas pour faut dire qu'on a des
émotions et j'ai pleuré j'ai pleuré de
voir cet hommage national qui n'aurait
jamais dû avoir lieu
j'ai pleuré parce que je vais vous dire
une chose j'en ai marre comme on dit
chez moi dans la drôme merde ça suffit
ça suffit
lorsque la police est attaqué c'est la
france qui est attaquée et moi je ne
supporte plus les circonvolutions les
explications il ya toujours que tu n'en
la police comme la gendarmerie sont des
sanctuaires républicains et les implore
un sanctuaire républicain est attaqué
c'est la république est attaquée c'est
la nation c'est la france et moi je
demande du
patriotisme je demande du courage je
demande qu'on se lève tous et tous pour
nos couleurs
pour la république pour le bleu blanc
rouge pour la france pour la nation
française parce qu'il n'est pas possible
que des gens des policiers une policière
un papa une maman qui sont là pour nous
protéger ces gens là je ne fais pas la
différence avec ceux qui sont dans les
manifs avec ceux qui seront bordés
reçues qui sont nos quartiers et je
voulais vous le dire ce matin avec à la
fois beaucoup d'émotion mais bon sang
mais vraiment je suis très touché parce
que c'est la france qui a été attaquée
et l'hommage qui a été rendu par le chef
de l'état ce matin à versailles était un
bel hommage et lorsqu'il s'est incliné
sur les cercueils physiquement lorsqu'il
a mis les deux mains de part et d'autre
du cercueil à la fois il tenait un
enfant de la république me le rendait
hommage à la république
le mien senti l'émotion dans votre
ouvrage on va aller évidemment dérouler
le fil de l'actualité de la semaine et
on va commencer par le lundi le sénat
s'empare de la loi travail et la droite
a décidé de fortement remaniée le texte
pour présenter un tout autre projet le
gouvernement espère de son côté
remobiliser la gauche contre cette
version de la droite explication dans un
climat de fronde sociale qui se prolonge
pour la loi travail l'heure est à la
séance publique au sénat où seront
étudiées pas moins de 900 amendements et
deux motions communiste sur la table le
texte amendé par la majorité sénatoriale
de droite plus souple selon eux plus
libérale pour d'autres c'est un texte où
il ya effectivement plus de souplesse
d'un certain nombre de domaines pour les
entreprises notamment les pme qui
étaient les grandes oubliées du texte
mais en même temps également où on met
plus de retour aux salariés la
commission chargée de relire le texte a
supprimé 12 articles finis la
généralisation de la garantie jeunes qui
permet le versement d'une allocation de
461 euros par mois fini également la
référence aux 35 heures
le nombre d'heures travaillées sera
décidée par un accord d'entreprise
en revanche le sénat a conservé le
principe de la hiérarchie des normes et
réintroduit la mesure de plafonnement
des indemnités de licenciement aux
prud'hommes
un retour en arrière selon la gauche qui
souhaitent profiter des débats pour
clarifier ses intentions
le sénat va être l'occasion de
poursuivre ce débat non pas entre nous
mais avec les français et donc mon
travail comme ceux de mes collègues du
groupe social essaie de faire la
pédagogie de la réforme c'est pas de
polémique s est de débattre faire de la
pédagogie pour apaiser les tensions et
patienter car si manuel valls s'est dit
ouvert aux propositions du sénat c'est
sans aucun doute le 49-3 qui aura le
dernier mot à l'assemblée nationale
alors dd vous voir revenir évidemment
cette idée du 49-3 un peu plus tard il
faudrait savoir ce que vous avez pensé
de cette première semaine de débats sur
la loi travail l'article 2 a été votée
c'est le fameux laboratoire de la droite
pour 2017 c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est la teneur des débats
oui je crois on a eu une longue semaine
de débats d'abord une discussion
générale qui était très intéressante
parce que à quoi sert une discussion
générale affirme et les orientations
politiques et nous les avons vus nous
avons vu la différence entre la droite
et la gauche
nous avons vu aussi et je l'assumé à
l'intérieur de la gauche
des différences d'appréciation et d'
analyse de quoi s'agit-il
la droite nous a dit pendant des
semaines et des semaines nous aurions
voté la première version mais dans le
texte actuel il n'y a rien eh bien les
débats ont montré toute cette semaine
que c'était faux que c'était de la
propagande politicienne
parce que dans ce texte il y avait
beaucoup de choses et la grande
différence entre le texte du sénat et ce
que nous voulons nous la gauche
sénatoriale ou ce que veut le
gouvernement
c'est la différence entre la régulation
et la déstructuration du coup ce texte
permet à la majorité de se ressouder
enfin de se ressouder la majorité
n'avait besoin la majorité n'est pas si
divisé que cela mais nous avons là oui
parce que vous avez il s'agit à
l'assemblée nationale de 24 députés dits
frondeurs face à 250 députés
forcément puisque nous n'avons pas de
majorité appartement où tous les députés
socialistes ne vote pas puisque nous
sommes majoritaires seul le groupe
socialiste avec nos alliés radicaux et
les écologistes réformiste mais voilà
donc elle est encore active notamment
assemblée ou qu'elle bat un peu de l'ale
mais moi je ne veux pas polémique je ne
vais pas aujourd'hui elle existe cette
fronde et je crois que nos amis
frondeurs nous amis députés veulent
taleo jusqu'au bout ils ont des
divergences avec nous avec le chef de
l'état avec le bio mais premier ministre
deux motions mais nous verrons comment
les choses se passeront peut-être une
motion de censure mais une motion de
censure de gauche ça n'existe pas
je vais vous le dire très tranquillement
une motion de censure de gauche ça
n'existe pas lorsque le gouvernement est
de gauche une motion de censure
c'est vous de vouloir faire tomber le
gouvernement donc si on veut faire
tomber le gouvernement
on n'est plus de gauche on n'est plus
dans la majorité ça voudrait dire quoi
et donc on n'est plus au parti
socialiste on n'est plus au groupe
socialiste
d'accord ça n'existait si vous avez les
vers de nouveaux de 43 il pourrait très
bien arriver vous est ce qu'il pourrait
arriver mais j'espère que ça n'existera
pas parce que je pense que cette loi
avec de l'argumentation lé vos tables et
sur quoi peut-il y avoir un compromis
autre que sur l'article 2 sur lesquels
il ya toujours des blocages on essaie de
réécrire de trouver une solution de
sortie sur quoi donnons mais on n'essaie
pas de s'cusez moi de trouver une
solution de sortie là et des réécrit
l'article 2 l'article 2 n'est pas viable
si nous devions le bouger c'est vrai ne
reviendrions sur le fond de la loi c'est
quoi si on effectue à l'article de pogo
téléspectateurs comprennent bien en une
minute
l'article 2 c'est donner la parole aux
salariés dans une entreprise si le vote
des syndicats est arrivé à 50%
c'est un peu de la technique mais donc
nous nous appelons ça de la
décentralisation sociale
nous voulons bâtir un nouveau contrat
social sur la base de nouveaux dialogue
social donc nouvelle la parole aux
salariés
ce n'est pas un recul vous allez voir
dans l'hémicycle des échanges ont été
plutôt vif aurait notamment avec vos
amis communistes passe encore vos amis
vous allez nous dire écoutez justement
cet échange entre myriam et de cabri et
de sénateur communiste christian favier
ces casseurs s'était quand même de
drôles de casseurs nous avons rencontré
qui ont pu agir devant une police
passive devant laurent exactions on a
même des photos le montrent aujourd'hui
on voit des policiers en civil avec des
brassards de police qui laissent faire
effectivement ces casseurs du cac
sur l'hôpital necker je le dis très
clairement les insinuations que venez de
faire
alors même quand on dénombre le nombre
de blessés qui lie h et les forces de
l'ordre
insinuer qui sont là en train d'exporter
les maîtres même plan que des casseurs
avec une telle violence qui s'est
déversé dans les rues de paris qui ont
attaqué un hôpital pour enfants malades
de l'hôpital necker
je trouve ces propos complètement
scandaleux légumes tension dans la rue
tension dans l'hémicycle également
williams en deux temps cieux de tension
je pense qu'il est lui un dérapage un
dérapage de nos amis communistes et
républicains et d'ailleurs moi
j'aimerais qu'ils y reviennent et la
présidente des gosses
la présidente du groupe crc eliane
assassi lorsqu'elle a pris la parole
après la suspension de séance à calmer
les choses peut demander des créations
faire des insinuations et dire que dans
les casseurs il y avait des policiers et
prendre les exemples de ce qui s'était
passé en 118 119 sur la sidérurgie ce
n'est pas acceptable aujourd'hui nous le
disions début d'émission
il n'ya pas les gentils flics et les
mauvais flic soit on est du côté de la
république et on soutient les flics mais
si on ne soutient pas les flics on est
borderline vis-à-vis de la république
quand même sur cette rencontre tenue en
fin de semaine entre myriam el khomri et
philippe martinez ils se sont vus mis un
désaccord total donc ça pourra plus
vraiment bougé mais nous le savons
qu'elle dit accord total avec la cgt la
cgt demander d'abord le retrait du texte
puis il semblerait qu'ils ne demandent
pas le retrait du texte au moment de la
suspension pourrait écrire l'article de
nos nous avons une divergence une
opposition fondamentale avec la cgt
c'est pas pour cela que la cgt ne signe
pas d'une quantité assez importante
d'accord ce n'est pas pour ça que la cgt
sur la corse où la sncf travaille sur la
loi travail il y à une opposition il
faut lactée et parallèlement pourquoi je
dis qu'on ne peut pas aller plus loin
parce que les syndicats réformistes la
cfdt laurent berger lorsque l'on entend
parler revenir à articule bien les
choses
la cfdt la cftc l'unsa la fage sont
favorables à cette loi des syndications
pour des syndicats sont contre nous nous
sommes du côté de la réforme la
social-démocratie affirmé et sereine que
nous voulons mettre en place nous la
mettons en place à partir de cette loi
on va y revenir tout à l'heure un peu
plus tard puisqu'il était à l'assemblée
laurent bergé et yves martinez mais en
attendant à l'assemblée c'est une autre
grande loi qui était alors due
pour la loi dite sapin de adopté mardi
en première lecture lutte contre la
corruption dans les grandes entreprises
encadrement des lobbys ou encore des
salaires de grands patrons mais aussi
protection des lanceurs dallaire voici
les diverses dispositions contenues dans
cette loi très large mari la bat
parmi les mesures les plus emblématiques
d'abord la création d'un véritable
statut pour les lanceurs d'alert
l'intention de la commission des lois a
l'intention de son rapporteur
évidemment c'est de protéger les
lanceurs d'alerté d'abord c'est grâce à
nos initiatives que nous allons les
protéger au meilleur niveau avec le
défenseur des droits une autorité
constitutionnellement gars dont
l'indépendance est constitutionnellement
garantis y figurent aussi la création
d'une agence contre la corruption ou
encore l'obligation de transparence sur
l'origine et les montant d'emprunt de
tout candidat à une élection
les grandes entreprises seront désormais
contrainte de faire du reporting public
c'est à dire de publier certaines
données sur leurs activités dans
certains pays comme leur chiffre
d'affaires ou leur impôt sur les
bénéfices
enfin la loi prévoit l'instauration d'un
registre de lobbyistes une nécessité
lorsque ceux ci sont en contact avec les
pouvoirs publics
l'autre objectif de la loi est aussi de
moderniser la vie économique
l'échec ne seront désormais valable que
six mois au lieu d'un an les conseils
d'administration des grandes entreprises
devront prendre en compte le vote des
assemblées générales d'actionnaires sur
la rémunération de leurs dirigeants
les artisans eux verront leur entrée sur
le marché du travail facilité par la vae
la validation des acquis de l'expérience
il ya quand même beaucoup de
dispositions très variés cette loi est
ce que pour vous c'est quand même
cohérent c'est un peu fourre tout c'est
un peu fourre tout cas si une loi de
cohérence la lutte contre la corruption
pour la transparence mais quand vous le
dites c'est pour tous parce qu'il a
fallu faire un très beau coup de chaud
ça vous aime très importante mais pas du
tout ou pas du tout au contraire la
cohérence et la transparence et la lutte
contre la corruption et la cellule
architecture la colonne vertébrale de ce
texte
on le voit sur beaucoup de sujets et
puis après il fallait faire entrer des
sujets d'actualité le salaire des grands
patrons par exemple
bon un moment ou un autre il faut que la
loi 10 disent des choses sur les
lanceurs d'alert la protection des
lanceurs d'alerté
c'est quand même essentiel est
essentielle donc voilà c'est à la fois
une colonne vertébrale la loi sapin de
restera comme une loi importante et
cette majorité qui la vote ce qui la
voterons parce que nous voulons lutter
fortement contrôlé quand la corruption
et puis vous savez le tout le passage
sur les lobbys mais on les voit dans le
couloir du sol et loris mais évidemment
mais qu'est ce que c'est
mais évidemment les lobbys sont à
l'assemblée nationale sont au sénat la
biodiversité dans les pays anglo saxons
c'est encore plus prégnant nous nous
avons besoin de deux d'encadrer
d'encadrer les choses que qu'edf grandes
associations qu'il y ait des des lobbys
des cabinets qui travaillent c'est bien
normal mais dans un cadre régulé dans
lequel de chez toi moi je trouve que
cette loi va dans le vraiment dans le
bon sens
transparence lutte contre la corruption
c'est essentiel dans notre pays nous
avons besoin d'exemplarité et les
politiques doivent faire la
démonstration qu'il ne cache rien qu'il
ne camoufle rien sur qui veulent aller
dans cette direction là a fortiori en
serre ce moment de deuil mardi députés
et sénateurs ont observé une minute de
silence à la mémoire du policier de sa
compagne sauvagement assassinée à
domicile sous les yeux de leur petit
garçon de 3 ans nouvelles victimes du
terrorisme islamisme est un échec
il défend l'action de son gouvernement
moi je ne laisserai pas dire qu'il ya eu
de la part de l'eau force chargée de la
lutte contre le terrorisme la moindre
négligence ni le moindre manque de
discernement car l'union nationale n'a
duré que le temps d'une minute de
recueillement
l'opposition n'a pas tardé à demander
des comptes certains réclament avant
tout une meilleure application de la loi
n'a pas besoin de nouvelles nous
il n'y a pas besoin d'inventer de
nouvelles solutions il faut appliquer
les textes un texte par exemple celui
qui réprime l'intelligence avec l'ennemi
qui est puni quand même d'une peine de
30 ans de prison
d'autres prônent un durcissement des
peines de prison ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça premier problème est
ce que les peines sont suffisantes
le juge trévidic lui même qui avait fait
l'instruction de cette affaire explique
qu'il faut sans doute durcir les peines
qui ne sont pas suffisantes pour garder
les gens davantage en prison et puis une
partie de la droite va plus loin
pourquoi ces personnes sont laissées en
liberté alors qu'elles sont connues et
identifiées
placé sur écoutes nous vous demandons
leur placement dans des centres de
rétention administrative
une idée que reprend le patron des
républicains je souhaite dans la lignée
d'ailleurs discret très bien dit eric
ciotti que soit désormais brise les
mesures d'assignation à résidence et de
rétention pour les individus soupçonnés
d agissements les plus dangereux qu'on
arrête de nous rebattre les oreilles
avec le principe de précaution
lorsqu'on n'est pas capable d'appliquer
le principe de précaution à la sécurité
des français
mais le gouvernement a déjà exclu la
création de tels centres en france je
crois vraiment il faut s'y tenir dans
des moments pareils nous ne jugeons pas
les intentions nous jugeons les faits
parce que si c'est une intention ça ne
se démontre est pas un fait ça se
condamne le conseil d'état s'est
d'ailleurs déjà prononcé contre la
création de centres de rétention pour
passer outre cette décision il faudrait
changer la constitution
voilà après le choc devant l'horreur les
questions les propositions sont
nombreuses
vous-même qu'est ce que vous dites qu
est ce qui peut être fait dit médias et
de fort pour qu'un tel acte aussi
barbare ne puisse pas se reproduire
je pense que dans un premier temps c'est
l'exemplarité et c'est la façon de faire
de la politique
si les responsables politiques utilisent
ces meurtres ces tueries à des fins
politiciennes pour la primaire de la
droite ou pour tout autre chose car je
crois que c'est le cas pour tout autre
chose ça veut dire que là c'est la fin
de notre république apaisée et sereine
que vous avez mangé reconnaissant
l'instant quand j'entends nicolas
sarkozy d'abord je dois dire que le
principe de précaution ça me fait
doucement rigoler c'est lui qui l'a
inscrit dans la constitution je n'y
étais pas favorable moitié de personnel
mais je pense qu'on ne doit pas aller
dans le populisme dans la démagogie dans
la course la plus folle à tout cela le
rôle d'un responsable politique surtout
lorsqu'il veut être président de la
république ou un nouveau président de la
république c'est de tracer la voie de
donner du sens ce n'est pas de courir
après parce que ceux qui pourront
toujours plus vite
geo répondent ceux qui vont toujours
plus vite c'est le front national et
c'est madame le pen
aujourd'hui on ne court pas après ses
lecteurs en leur expliquait hier il n'ya
rien excuser ces actes sont inexcusables
mais dire comme monsieur wauquiez ou
comme d'autres faut tous les mettre en
prison
c'est absolument ahurissant et salyers
et puis d'ailleurs on voit bien ce qui
se passe aux etats-unis il ya la peine
de mort il ya le port d'armes ni à
guantanamo et il ya eu orlando il faut
une réponse forte mais la réponse elle
est forte c'est l'état de droit
il faut expliquer à nos concitoyens tout
somme devant être adroit malgré l'état
d'urgence et donc si nous voulons
revenir sur l'état de droit si nous
voulons qu'un pouvoir politique puisse
emprisonné puisse arrêter des gens comme
l'a très bien dit le garde des sceaux
jean jacques urvoas sur des intentions
et pas sur des faits alors nous
changeons de système politique
nous ne changeons donc oui c'est
difficile pour mes lors la législative
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
oui c'est suffisant l'arsenal législatif
et suffisance il faut amender des trois
choses mais je veux le dire vraiment
sans polémique mais je pense que c'est
la chose essentielle de ce qui s'est
passé ces dernières années quand nous
entendons les leçons de sarkozy juppé
fillon et consorts
alors qu'ils ont détruit détruit les
postes dans l'éducation nationale dans
la police dans la gendarmerie dans la
justice par dizaines de milliers et que
maintenant nous on nous fait la leçon
ce n'est pas acceptable ce sont eux qui
ont mis la justice la police et la
gendarmerie dans cet état avec un manque
de moyens nous sommes en train par les
lois de finances successives de créer
des postes et nous faisons mais si on
veut que les gendarmes les policiers la
justice et les moyens faut pas leur
supprimer des postes alors qu'on dit
ça on entend dans l'hémicycle aux
cédantes dit oui mais c'est encore
l'héritage ça fait quatre ans que vw
ça fait quatre ans que vous gouvernez
nous fait pas le coup de l'héritage
je vous le fais pas que nous nous créons
les postes nous nous réparons ce qu'ils
ont abîmé des des listes ont été
retrouvés dans le le meurtrier la rosa
aval à l'art aussi à malahidh et des
élus se retrouvent sur cette liste
notamment est ce que vous même vous êtes
inquiet ou fataliste non mais je pense
que tout le monde est inquiet comme
ainsi pleinement les inquiet parce que
les cibles c'est tout chacun est une
cible potentielle
mais en même temps la force l'unité de
la france de la nation que nous
évoquions au début de de votre émission
c'est ça qui doit être plus fort si le
patriotisme cessé de défendre pays
l'idée c'est à ce moment là pardon
l'union sacrée oui mais à ce moment là
encore déclaré à ce moment là qu'il faut
se rassembler dès le soir même de
l'assassinât de ces deux personnes la
droite fait entendre une voix différente
on ne gagne pas des élections sur les
drames
ça ne peut pas exister donc que nous
ayons des programmes différents
on va attendre que ce qui va se passer
pour la primaire de la droite et puis il
y aura l'élection présidentielle on aura
des programmes différents les français
jugeront et le peuple français a
toujours raison donc qui votera pour qui
voudra à voter mais par contre
aujourd'hui
moi ce que je demande l'appel solennel
que je fais devant vous ce matin c'est
pas un appel à une énième union
nationale à l'union sacrée
c'est l'appel à la responsabilité devant
le peuple de france
la france est divisée la france est
fracturée les français sont inquiets
les français ont du mal à à savoir où
ils vont
mais il ne peut pas y avoir la
cacophonie mardi toujours on va passer
aux manifestations qui ont eu lieu un
peu partout en france et surtout à paris
les violences ont cette fois été
beaucoup plus importante de nombreuses
dégradations des policiers des
manifestants blessés l'hôpital pour
enfants en équerre pris pour cible par
les casseurs c'est du jamais vu a dit
manuel valls j'imagine que là aussi vous
avez été choqué oui c'est du jamais vu
et ce n'est pas acceptable
aujourd'hui il faut que tous les
républicains de tous bords se disent que
voulons nous nous voulons une république
apaisée
nous voulons que la démocratie politique
la démocratie représentative n'importe
où nous voulons laisser tout le reste et
je vous le disais c'est la suite de ce
que nous disions à l'instant ce n'est
pas sain lorsque les uns et les autres
font des instituts à sion non les
communistes hier soir en séance la
droite d'un côté ce n'est pas ça
justement didier guillaume pour rebondir
ce que ce que vous dites bernard
cazeneuve cette semaine devant la
représentation nationale s'est montré
très énervé il s'est indigné contre eux
justement ce genre de comportement de
vous parler je vous propose de réécouter
cette séquence moi je ne peux plus
supporter comme ministre de l'intérieur
alors que je vois la dignité de ces
policiers que je vois les souffrances
accumulées que je vois les familles
déchirées derrière les cercueils pas
simplement lorsque les policiers sont
atteints par des actes terroristes mais
aussi lorsqu'ils sont atteints par la
violence quotidienne qui prend dans ce
pays comme en europe des proportions
qu'elle ne devrait pas prendre
je ne peux plus supporter ces postures
ses propos ces affiches qui met en cause
ceux qui portent l'uniforme et qui a
raison de l'uniforme qu'ils portent
incarne le droit discours de vérité il a
raison ah oui moi je partage absolument
et moi j'en ai marre aussi supporter
plus je vous disais tout à l'heure ce
n'est pas possible si nous sommes
français
nous devons soutenir les forces de
l'ordre savez moi je les connais j'ai
une pensée pour ceux de la drôme pour le
commissaire pierre olivier maroc et le
directoire départemental pour tous les
policiers les flics gendarmes que je
connais je leur apporter toute ma
solidarité tout mon soutient enfin
qu'est ce que c'est cette histoire
ils sont là pour nous protéger on va les
montrer du doigt confrères en frais des
insinuations pour dire ils font partie
des casseurs où il laisserait les
casseurs cassé mais nous vivons nous
dans quel monde vivons-nous comportement
indigne inacceptable acceptable indigne
tout ce que vous voulez moi je vous mets
tous les qualificatifs tous les
superlatifs
je combattrai de toutes mes forces
celles et ceux d'août ils viennent qui
mettront en cause d'or aux républicains
qui mettront en cause la justice la
police et la jeunesse qu'il ya une
haine anti-flic selon vous en france
mais le 11 janvier les français embrasse
et leighlin a comment expliquer
qu'aujourd'hui au jour lors bien de ce
oui mais c'est mon raisonnement ce ne
sont pas les mêmes le 11 janvier les des
français dans la manifestation embrasser
des flics et aujourd'hui on leur tape
dessus mais ce qui leur tape dessus sont
des casseurs sont des no border sont des
black box sondés sont des gens d'extrême
d'extrémistes veulent faire taper taper
notre pays notre notre république c'est
pour ça que les républicains doivent
s'unir pas pour une union sacrée
mais pour combattre cela dans le
contexte actuel est ce que il vous
semblerait raisonnable de prolonger
l'état d'urgence
je peux pas répondre à cette question il
est prolongé jusqu'à près 26 juillet
voilà jusqu'après le tour de france pour
les grands événements saisi pour une
deuxième fois
oui tu es 2e ou 3e fouet mais après je
ne sais pas envers allemand mut je ne
suis pas sûr c'est pas prolonger l'état
d'urgence pour l'état d'urgence l'état
d'urgence est pas l'état d'urgence
permanent s'est donné les moyens au
service je crois qu'ils ont eu les
moyens de faire ce qu'ils avaient à
faire
les moyens pour la sécurité de l'euro
pour les sculpter du tour de france
après moi je pense qu'il fera peut-être
s'arrêter mais je peux pas répondre à
cette question je vous le dis
franchement ce matin là alors il ya la
question qui a été posée cette semaine
aux députés comme aux sénateurs c'est de
savoir s'il fallait interdire les
manifestations reportage cependant parmi
les violences qui ont une nouvelle fois
précédé le cortège des manifestants
contre la loi travail à paris ont
suscité de nombreuses réactions de
politique désormais manuel valls
envisage d'interdire certaines
manifestations pour préserver l'ordre
public cas par cas car vous savez on
peut pas prononcer une interdiction
générale
nous prendrons nous nos responsabilités
en conseil des ministres françois
hollande a précisé qu'il n'y aura plus
d'autorisation de manifester si la
préservation des biens et des personnes
ne pouvait être garantie
la cgt a évidemment réagi en publiant un
communiqué sur son site
le syndicat estime que le respect de la
sécurité est avant tout la
responsabilité des pouvoirs publics et
non celle des manifestants participant à
une marche autorisée par la préfecture
de police
la cgt ajoute que la menace d'interdire
les manifestations est le signe d'un
gouvernement aux abois
si la préservation de la sécurité et
bien du ressort des pouvoirs publics
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
estime que la cgt n'êtes pas la
préfecture a organisé une manifestation
dans le calme
je ne dis pas tu la cgt est responsable
de la violence je constate qu'à chaque
manifestation
aujourd'hui il y à de la violence face
aux militants républicains nicolas
sarkozy va plus loin
pour lui la cgt doit payer pour les
dégâts causés en marge de la
manifestation
je demande que soit engagée la
responsabilité civile et financières de
la cgt qui a organisé la manifestation
la cgt n'était pas la seule à appeler à
manifester hier à paris sept syndicats
étaient réunis lors de cette
manifestation
évidemment plusieurs questions se
posaient la première c est ce qu'il faut
est à dire ces manifestations à partir
de maintenant moi je ne suis pas
favorable à l'interdiction par principe
des manifestations sont un droit
constitutionnel le droit de manifester à
lille et rennes sont en haut mais mais
mais en l'état actuel des choses les
manifestations ne sont plus tenables
donc s'il n'y avait pas des garanties
fortes sur le parcours sur l'encadrement
et sur la possibilité que ces
manifestations se devait y en avoir à
nouveau se tiennent bien
alors oui je pense qu'il faudrait tenter
s'égarant bay à la fois le service
d'ordre de l'est bien sûr comme il était
bien sûr bien sûr le service d'ordre
les responsables des syndicats avec la
police la préfecture de police de paris
et le gouvernement
moi c'est nicolas sarkozy montre du
doigt la cgt la cité c'est pas ça à
manuel valls aussi non non non c'est
andy pas la cgt est responsable je dis
simplement que aujourd'hui philippe
martinez oui il a dit que les propos
tenus par manuel valls cette semaine et
est irresponsable mais il y est revenu
parce qu'il a condamné ce matin ce qui
s'est passé l'hôpital necker donc moi ça
me va
d'accord un dirigeant syndical qui ne
condamne pas la violence pour moi c'est
un problème
il l'a fait ce matin dans tact d'accord
je dis simplement que la sécurité autour
et dans la manif c'est une collaboration
avec les services de l'état évidemment
mais le service d'ordre de la cgt si le
service d'ordre de la cgt de fo des
manifestations n'est pas en état
d'assurer la sécurité dans la
manifestation
alors il faut rentrer a été en mesure
d'assurer cette sécurité puisque les
casseurs s'en sont pris à l'hôpital
necker ont été hospitalisés des enfants
à deux pas du bloc opératoire
comment éviter que ce genre d'événement
se reproduise qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour pour arrêter les gars sait déjà que
tout le monde se retrouve sur un appel
au calme et un appel à la république
nous en parlions je n'y reviens pas nous
l'avons beaucoup développé ensuite c'est
de se poser la question de est-ce que
c'est une prochaine manifestation peut
être tenu ou pas eh bien il ya des
spécialistes ne suis pas un croisement
et le 23 juin la police les syndicats
les services d'ordre
il doit y avoir une réunion si la
première flotte police dit je pense que
ce parcours est trop long ou devrait pas
passer par là et que les syndicats
disent on s'en fiche on passe quand même
par la photographe pose un problème
donc il faut à prendre des décisions par
nicolas sarkozy à l'instant et demande à
ce que ce soit la cgt qui paye les pots
cassés
oui mais enfin ça tout ça c'est de la
politique politicienne il en train de
vouloir faire de la cerise su par
rapport aux autres candidats de la
primaire à droite c'est la course à
l'échalote
moi ça ne m'intéresse pas mais ça c'est
déjà arrivé des syndicats
d'évaluation ça a été demandé au riz
culteurs s'était demandé à d'autres
syndicats s'étaient demandé aux
associations je crois pour les manifs
pour le mariage contre le mariage e pour
tous donc on verra le moment venu
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est pas de
dire à la cgt payez ce que vous avez
fait ça n'a aucun sens qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait faut faire un certain nombre de
vérifications
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire comment la
tranquillité des parisiens et des
français peut être retrouvé et en en fin
de semaine dernière c'étaient les
hooligans qui s'en prenaient à marseille
même dans son île de france la huitième
manifestation ces débordements et la
droite nous accuse de ne plus rien tenir
évitement de l'état et même de ce
gouvernement qui ne tient plus rien qui
soit il a droit
nous accusons pourrait devenir la droite
nous accuse absolument de tout de tout
mais les hooligans
la justice a fait son oeuvre la police a
fait ce qu'elle avait à faire dire c'est
de la faute à françois hollande doit
bernard cazeneuve que des russes et des
anglais son clapet dessus franchement là
on a touché le fond du fond du fond de
la basse politique en revenons à
l'assemblée ou deux têtes d'affiché
syndicale a été reçue
laurent berger et philippe martinez
d'un côté les frondeurs qui ont reçu
philippe martinez de l'autre laurent
berger qui était avec bruno le roux pour
une réunion de travail sur les syndicats
et la réforme retour sur cette séquence
ils n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot
les frondeurs opposés à la loi travail
ont décidé de recevoir l'ensemble des
syndicats en audition une action qu'ils
appellent le marathon du dialogue
on essaie de voir comment on pourrait
amener ensemble le syndicat députés sur
la table des propositions qui
permettraient trouver un compromis et de
sortir un peu de cette crispation qui
fracturent la la gauche sociale
politique syndicale le numéro un de
force ouvrière jean claude mailly s'est
rendu à cette audition toujours très
agacé par l'attitude de la majorité
socialiste
ce sont des députés de la majorité qui
ont demandé à nous voir moi je suis
toujours prêt au dialogue avec tout le
monde
si bruno le roux va devoir et devant le
groupe socialiste je viens quand il veut
pour les syndicats ce sont les dernières
négociations en coulisse leur objectif
faire évoluer la loi
montrer que la mobilisation était
toujours importante et donc on est en
phase avec l'opinion publique donc voilà
il faut que le gouvernement sache
écouter en entendre et tout pourra aller
pour le mieux de son côté le groupe
socialiste de l'assemblée recevait le
numéro un de la cfdt sur le thème du
syndicalisme réformiste
l'occasion pour laurent berger de
confirmer son soutien au gouvernement
c'est une loi de progrès en progrès
social et dans un moment où certains
voudraient nous faire croire que c'est
plus possible progrès social parce que
la situation est trop dur parce que il
faut d'abord se ressent très simplement
sur l'économique et bien je crois leur
avoir fait témoignage en tout cas que
c'est une wag progrès social un
compromis est il encore possible
réponse début juillet quand la loi
reviendra à l'assemblée
je reprends tout simplement agression un
compromis était encore possible avec un
tel écart de position je l'espère mais
je n'en suis pas sûr
laurent berger bien très bien de le dire
cette loi est une loi de progrès social
sédunois qui repose sur un triptyque
l'efficacité économique pour les
entreprises c'est essentiel et
aujourd'hui les mêmes qui critiquaient
le cic eux le crédit impôt compétitivité
emploi une critique plus et qu'à voir
hier
les chiffres qui ont été annoncés ils
vont dans le bon sens quand françois
hollande dit ça va mieux personne ne le
croit évidemment les personnes en temps
mais évidemment mais je voulais je vous
le dis mais pour la france et pour les
chiffres économiques macroéconomiques
pour le pouvoir d'achat pour la dette ça
va mieux
bon voilà les frondeurs reçoivent
monsieur martinez et monsieur mailly
pour essayer de trouver un compromis
avec eux ne trouvent pas un compromis
qu'avec une partie on trouve un
compromis avec l'ensemble est donc le
compromis que nous devons trouver s'il
devait y en avoir un c'est un compromis
avec tous les syndicats
les syndicats majoritaires que je tienne
la loi comme les autres ça ne peut pas
être écoutés le compromis ne peut pas
être une reddition en rase campagne
pour les promoteurs de la loi nous
allons dans le bon sens une voie de
progrès social une loi de juste
équilibre
il y aura pas de répit l'article de ne
rien n'aura pas je crois pas mais ni
pour les uns ni pour l'autre de la
fermeté après s'il doit y avoir des
choses qui avancent des sujets qui
avance sur le droit sur le sur les
heures supplémentaires si ça doit
avancer sur la médecine du travail
pourquoi pas je n'en sais rien à l'heure
qu'il est mais si le mot d'ordre c'est
cette loi n'est pas bonne et il faut la
retirer ou la suspendre
je n'y suis pas favorable pourrait
passer par quoi on met tout le monde
autour de la table on fait une petite
pause dans le débat parlementaire
non parce que faire une pause dans le
débat parlementaire c'est faire de
l'antiparlementarisme dire que les
parlementaires s'arrête de débattre
s'arrête de débattre parce qu'il va se
passer des choses ailleurs alors c'est
plus la peine qu'on ait des parents par
pause mais on peut dès lors à côté
le sénat va jusqu'au bout voter- à son
texte le 28
juin à partir du 28 juin le parlement
aura des battues en première lecture à
l'assemblée et au sénat avec un 49,3
l'assemblée se fait partie de l'arsenal
législatif et avec le texte de la droite
au sénat
nous comparons les deux textes celui de
du gouvernement et celui de la droite
nous verrons les différences et puis là
nous arriverons en deuxième lecture à
l'assemblée en dernière lecture pour
avoir un nouveau texte
d'ici là le gouvernement le premier
ministre myriam el khomri dont je veux
vraiment saluer le courage fait un
travail est vraiment aléatoire et
trouvant un compromis jean paul doit
doit doivent avancer pour que cette loi
atterrissent et si dans les discussions
je sais pas ce qui s'est dit ce matin
avec monsieur marionnettes qui est sorti
6 6 1 des accords y aura des accords y
aura des accords sur d'autres choses
mais un désaccord sur cette loi
voilà et puis la loi sera promulguée il
faut avancer alors jean ferrat c'est
nous à rejoindre ne pas partager un
mythe l'aéro ça fait un bout de quelques
secondes
bonjour didier guillaume un bon joueur
va parler un peu de 2017 et du parti
socialiste
cette semaine le tribunal de paris a
débouté trois militants socialistes qui
réclamait l'application des statuts sur
la primaire lacombe de la justice a
considéré que les statuts étaient un peu
trop ambigu sur le sujet est-ce que la
primaire à gauche est définitivement
morte et enterrée vous rendez compte
quand même la vie politique
las il y avait des manifestations et
deux policiers assassinés le chef de
l'état leur rend hommage et nous on
parle de trois militants qui vont au
tribunal pour les statuts du parti
c'est honteux c'est la lente ça c'est ce
n'est pas à la hauteur et demain dans la
world conseil national
si au cours de ce conseil national
l'enjeu c'est une bataille entre les
frondeurs et la direction du parti
socialiste pour savoir quand aura lieu
la désignation de notre candidat
eh ben je pense que le parti socialiste
aura bien mal c'est une somme bien loin
bien loin de tout c'est une question
mais c'est pas la question essentielle
est porteur de ballon qui va ressortir
mais demain ce qu'il faudra fois que
nous parlions de l'actualité politique
de la sécurité de la
un travail du social et puis évidemment
nous parlerons de la primaire alors j'y
viens moi je viens je réponds à votre
question mais permettez moi de faire ce
que le parti n'est pas à la hauteur
le parti doit être à la hauteur il doit
il être
et si il n'est pas à cause de qui à
cause de trois minutes ans que je répète
que je peux je respecte qui font cela à
cause d'un seul entre dany frondeurs qui
passent leur temps à critiquer à
critiquer à dire qu'elle ne va cette
primaire nous y sommes favorables à une
primaire de toute la gauche sera t-elle
possible visiblement non alors après ou
devons-nous aller il faudra que nous
ayons un candidat fois que nous le
légitime ion moi je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent que françois hollande
je réponds à votre question que vous
m'avez pas posée malgré les sondages et
la pause malgré les sondages malgré la
cote de popularité malgré tout cela sera
le moment venu dans un an le meilleur
candidat capable de rassembler 100 des
cas pas venu primaire est capable de
tenir il faudra qu'il soit légitime et
on est ce que c'est une primaire est ce
que c'est une désignation je n'en sais
rien encore ne devant nous deux
référents donc nous devons en parler et
nous allons le faire mais c'est pas le
point essentiel référence est pas le
point essentiel
je pense aujourd'hui que veulent nos
concitoyens que veulent voter les
spectateurs vos téléspectateurs se fiche
totalement
des débats internes du ps alors arnaud
montebourg à une réflexion quand même
cette semaine sur qui concernait tout
l'exécutif fait pas uniquement la
question la primaire il a parlé du coup
de force permanent qu'est ce que vous
lui répondez parce qu'il menace du coup
de passer en dehors du processus de la
primaire et de se présenter directement
la présidentielle si jamais elle n'a pas
lieu est ce que ça peut être un danger
pour françois hollande
je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes à un
tournant les socialistes sont un
tournant
vont ils rester ensemble où vont-ils se
séparés divorcés et faire des chemins
différents
moi j'aimerais j'emploie le conditionnel
que nous restions ensemble que les
socialistes restent ensemble parce que
nous avons des approches différentes
mais nous faisons partie d'une même
histoire d'une même culture jaurès blum
mitterrand jospin en 97 et maintenant
mots qui sont et maintenant mon goût
relents de force permanent mais oui le
rassemblement il n'existe pour l'heure
voit bien le jeu
mo mitterrandiste le coup d'état
permanent du coup de force permanent
mais si le choix d'arnaud montebourg et
de ses amis c'est de quitter le parti
socialiste pour se présenter pour faire
en sorte que assurément nous aurons un
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle entre marine le pen et
nicolas sarkozy ou alain juppé
eh bien ils prennent leurs
responsabilités vous savez aujourd'hui
minoritairement il ya peut-être des
socialistes qui préféreraient voter au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle pour un candidat de
droite que de voter au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle pour françois
hollande ce n'est pas mon cas c'est
difficile mais moi je veux que tous les
socialistes toutes les femmes et les
hommes de gauche qui ont une
responsabilité se disent
l'enjeu c'est le deuxième tour avant on
était sûr d'être au deuxième tour
aujourd'hui on n'est pas sûr d'y arriver
mais personne ne sera pris par surprise
un prêt et que vous pouvez dire via
social il a déjà passé donc le parti
socialiste peut exploser fera en tout
cas peut se diviser mais pas une grande
explosion une petite partie le quitterez
et l'autre une grande partie restauré ce
n'est pas ma vision
moi je souhaite que nous restions
ensemble mais je ne voudrais pas et je
termine là dessus parce que c'est très
important que les mêmes qui trouveraient
que françois hollande n'est pas assez à
gauche et n'irait pas voter pour lui en
avril 2017 soit le 1er mai 2010 est dans
la rue pour appeler à faire barrage à
l'extrême droite et soit le 6 ou le 7
mai 2010 est appelé à voter pour nicolas
sarkozy parce que là franchement ça
serait compliqué pour éviter tout ça il
faudrait que la candidature de françois
hollande s'impose d'elle-même c'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui on voit encore des
sondages cette semaine qu'ils sont en
baisse pour françois hollande mélenchon
qui passe devant hollande au premier
tour dans un sondage
et pourtant et pourtant la situation
économique vous le disiez elle repart là
mon sens a été réévalué à la hausse pour
hier comment ça se fait que françois
hollande n'arrive pas à capitaliser là
dessus et vous avez l'impression que
ça s'impose la nature chez les
républicains je crois pas non plus à ma
question non mais c'est ma réponse je
vais vous répondre précisément
je dis simplement qu'aujourd'hui tous
les partis sont en crise la politique
est en crise
donc les français ne voient pas les
choses ni à droite il n'y a pas
d'enthousiasmé pour voter à droite ni à
gauche il n'y a pas d'enthousiasmé porté
à gauche parce que ce soit 12 ou à 14
pour les uns ou pour les autres
excusez moi c'est pas un grand succès
bon pourquoi parce que ce quinquennat
était un quinquennat difficile un
championnat qui l'a fracturée il a
fracturé la gauche donc aujourd'hui il
faut absolument que nous arrivions nous
approprier les bons résultats certains
ne dépende absolument pas de nous tant
mieux s'il ya un peu de chances pour les
français et pour la france c'est d'eux
dont il s'agit certains dépendent de
nous la croissance le pouvoir d'achat la
baisse des impôts il faut comptabiliser
stationnement du gros saule en sera
demain au mont valérien pour célébrer
l'appel du 18 juin il était déjà lundi à
colombes et sur la tombe du général de
gaulle c'est quoi c'est le nouveau
jaurès pour françois hollande en vue
2010 est non je ne crois pas sanaria
avec 2017 faut pas toujours tout
replacer pour la présidentielle si
j'avais moi il m'arrive de voir il m'a
rien alors gaulliste qu il m'arrive de
voir françois hollande eux régulièrement
il est pas obnubilé par 2010 elle est
aujourd'hui l'époque du vide et par 2017
simplement il était l'année dernière
vous le disiez déjà au moment derrière
pour le 18 juin c'est normal le général
de gaulle a été celui qui a libéré la
france
ça a été un grand chef d'état nous
l'avons combattu politiquement nous
avons combattu politiquement mais après
c'est la quantité de l'arrivée
politiques peuvent-ils tirées du
gaullisme aujourd'hui parce que c'est
une référence qui revient
non mais il s'agit pas de ne s'agit pas
de tirer des leçons
par contre nous pouvons nous retrouver
le général de gaulle sur une certaine
idée de la france sur une certaine idée
de la nation sur une certaine idée du
patriotisme et sur une certaine idée du
vivre ensemble
eh bien on va se terminer sur on va
terminer cette émission sur ces paroles
là merci beaucoup d d'aiguillon dans
merci à vous et le parlement hebdo est
très bonne semaine à tous